Chuck I've been public on the fact that
I'm waiting for someone to convince me
that we don't live in a simulation this
is I've heard you say the arguments put
forth have been quite convincing okay me
and most of the best arguments are
traceable to a guy named Nick Bostrom a
philosopher at the University of Oxford
okay here's the argument ready go ahead
our computing power is growing rapidly
right we create simulations of worlds we
have video games with characters that
are inside the video game right imagine
a day where you can simulate a world so
perfectly with life-forms humans so well
that you can recreate every single
neurosynaptic thought you could have but
now you're in the simulation on the
computer so including the perception of
free will well there you have it because
then so now you would have enough
computing power to imbue the Sims inside
of the program with all of the human
traits that we possess now correct not
only our human trait not the one but the
world the world itself right and you
don't have to have all the world
existing there at all times right that
might be an unrealistic amount of
computing power right you just need
enough of the world that they see around
doesn't if they see around them so you
want to start digging and yes I'll find
I haven't put the earth there if there's
a flag that goes up in the programmer
and they say up need more earth stuff
right put earth beneath you well you can
keep digging it's like The Truman Show
yeah well for example foot right okay
cool
does minecraft you can build right right
oh that is mine crap right okay god that
guy's a genius
so we went to the moon it's okay let's
make sure line is there okay maybe
that's why we can't travel faster than
the speed of light because if we could
we'd be able to get to another galaxy or
they can program a program so much fun
so the programmer put in that limit but
in the limit because that's suspended
like the weekend we can program so we
put in a limiter who this me the light
is a limiter so that you can't get to
the next thing before we build it ah so
let me feel it that's good go ahead good
Chuck all right so let me finish it so
now so now that world Eve
and they developed computing power right
and they say we want to play video games
so now we're gonna make a world so then
they make a world and they have
sufficient computing power that they
invent right to create a whole universe
within their computers okay and then
they make a world and then they make a
world all the way on down right it could
be hundreds of thousands billions
infinite all right so so far this sounds
like it's still work it's right so now
close your eyes throw a dart which of
these universes are you gonna land in
the first one that's real or the
gazillion that are not well yeah just
statistically ok am i drinking when
we're playing this darts game ok cuz
then you miss dad to everything here
there's something called Bayesian
statistics where you're allowed to
introduce information that you already
have available to you even if you didn't
measure it to be true
so we establish the likelihood that one
day will have the power to do this right
and then that factors into these
statistics ok so this one in a zillion
you're the real universe and 999
bazillion to one that you're a
simulation simulation that convinced me
yeah and I don't want to be convinced I
didn't like it and I was just begging
for somebody to to give me an argument
that was cogent enough to undermine that
entire reasoning and I just came across
one oh ok ok
it's a good friend mind rich got all
right he was a colleague of mine back
when I was at Princeton all right deep
thinker likes calculating the ends of
things nice with Bayesian statistics
he's heavily quoted in this book the
doomsday calculation and William
Poundstone is smart guy unto himself and
I am now convinced now you're convinced
are you ready okay go ahead what do all
these units so here is what convinced me
we are not in a simulation ok are you
seated all right I'm seated are you put
hold on I'm gonna hold ok all right
what do all those simulated universes
have in common they're simulations they
can they have the power to simulate they
have the power to simulate them well ok
yes that is they all make a simulation
there's that power exactly
to simulate themselves exactly do we
have that power now no we don't know we
don't which means that we can't send it
in we can't send ourselves into the
future as a simulation because Omega
power we can't continue to change
we're so either we are the real one
right or we're the one in the chain
that's still evolving to try to then
make a simulation within their own world
right so the odds of us being a
simulation goes from a gazillion to one
that mean front to tip that the
likelihood of her life right right it
flips it flips 50-50 well I'm good with
that that changes my life yeah yeah okay
and no longer are your kids gonna say
dad it doesn't matter in a simulation
anyway no you got an argument remember
but exactly a quick one great good maybe
these simulators have a side activity
where they like reminiscing about days
before you could simulate that would be
us so now we're donkey kong donkey car
we're a classic classic game pic so
maybe we're just entertainment like a
historical exercise right that's
possible in principle however let's look
at our own conduct with that regard okay
I think of a movie as a simulation just
for the sake of what's the kind of
conversation which a kind of pen is ask
yourself how many movies have been made
in a time before we ever knew how to
make movies relative to movies made in
the era where we know how to make movies
you can do the numbers it's small yes
the Spartacus there's the OK Corral I
Musketeers yeah those exist that type of
stuff okay okay if we are any measure of
the incentives of creating simulations
which all we can do with movies at this
point then they might have some
historical thing but there's way more
interesting things and stories to tell
in the era of simulations that exist
post simulation right and that and that
yeah so even if there are some period
pieces that we might be still most of
these would be
universe is made after they could
simulate themselves right our
moviemaking habits or any indication of
anything so the chances are we're not a
little offshoot like a little society
could be just statistically it's
probably right because many because
we're throwing darts right and most of
the stories they're gonna simulate are
going to be the ones that they that are
in the era of the time they could
simulate themselves so that still brings
us back to we're probably either the
first or we're on our way to be in the
next on our way to being the next that's
correct
one is a we're that's more likely than
any other possibility here and so I'm so
I can now rest well at night so no
simulation yeah I'm good I think I'm
real I think you're real I think we're
good well real recognize real so yes
[Laughter]
real recognize real there you go Chuck
boom
start talking yes I do
[Music]